[Applaus]
[Musik]
island das einzige was ihr vielleicht
mit island assoziiert ist der eurovision
song contest falls ihr überhaupt zu
denjenigen gehört die sich so etwas
ansehen
aber was ihr vielleicht nicht fest
estland ist in so vielen bereichen ein
vorreiter dass man es mit recht dass
europäisches silikon in berlin hier
wurden unternehmen wie skype oder trends
verweis gekonnt und das ist erstaunlich
wenn man bedenkt dass dieses land noch
folgt 30 jahren teil der sowjetunion war
tatsächlich ist die situation ist alles
andere als einfach das wetter ist
einfach ekelhaft mit weniger als drei
stunden tageslicht im winter außerdem
befindet sich das land in einer endlosen
demografischen krise zu lösen fast
unmöglich erscheint im gegensatz zu den
meisten ländern hat estland einen weit
höheren anteil an weiblicher als an
männliche bevölkerung
das bedeutet dass durch die fehlenden
männer auch die fortpflanzungsrate
niedriger ist als in anderen ländern
und deshalb sinkt die bevölkerungszahl
von jahr zu jahr
doch trotz all dem ist es land quasi das
modernste land in ganz europa
tatsächlich ist es die einzige nation in
der die verfassung ihren bürgern den
internetzugang garantiert aber der
eigentliche grund warum estland einen
platz in der ruhmeshalle der staaten
dieser erde hat ist die sogenannte
residenz
das bedeutet jede person ganz gleich
welcher herkunft kein ein formular
ausfüllen und ein virtueller bürger des
landes werden aber was bedeutet das
eigentlich heute werden wir euch das
genauer erklären aber lasst uns erst
noch einen blick in die geschichte
werfen erste opfer von wladimir putin im
jahr 1991 erlangte es land die
unabhängigkeit von der sowjetunion ja
ich weiss andere länder wie weißrussland
oder die ukraine wurden zur gleichen
zeit unabhängig aber der unterschied
besteht darin dass in diesen fällen die
neuen demokratisch gewählten regierungen
immer noch stark unter dem einfluss
ehemaliger kommunistischer eliten
standen in estland war das anders
ihr erster demokratischer
premierminister makler bildete ein
kabinett mit einem durchschnittsalter
von 30 jahren das waren junge leute mit
neuen ideen die nicht mehr in der schuld
der alten sowjet gestanden und so hat
estland von heute auf morgen seine
wirtschaft zu den internationalen markt
geöffnet
sie nahmen eine kapitalistische
wirtschaftspolitik an und ein ziemlich
einzigartiges system der
staatsverwaltung das durch seinen
minimalismus heraus stach eigentlich ist
dies das wort das land besser als jedes
andere definiert minimalismus selbst
estlands flagge ist eine vereinfachte
darstellung der traditionellen land
und auch die besteuerung folgt in island
im sogenannten flat tax ist was bedeutet
das nun jetzt hat jeder den gleichen
prozentsatz egal wie viel er verdient
einkommenssteuer beträgt pauschal nur 20
prozent mit diesen regelungen ist es
leicht verständlich dass estland sehr
bald ausländische investitionen
angezogen hat insbesondere aus finnland
und den anderen skandinavischen ländern
[Musik]
dennoch war das nicht genug um so zu
wachsen die es nötig war denn anfang der
90er jahre hatten zum beispiel nur die
hälfte aller haushalte einen telefon-
und auch die restliche infrastruktur aus
der zeit der sowjetunion war vollkommen
unzureichend und marode wie ihr euch
vorstellen könnt sind dies keine idealen
voraussetzungen um ein wirtschaftswunder
herbeizuzaubern da man sowieso nicht
genug geld hatte um straßen für autos zu
bauen beschloss man wenigstens jene
mittel die überhaupt zur verfügung
standen
in die sagenumwobenen datenautobahnen zu
investieren und so kam es dass 15 jahre
später die ersten als erste auf der welt
überhaupt ihr parlament über das
internet gehen konnten aber langsam
wenn all diese reformen waren nicht ohne
gewisse opfer zu haben während dieser 15
jahre des fortschritts wurde die
russische minderheit die früher über
estland herrschte politisch isoliert aus
diesem grunde beschloss der kreml im
jahr 2007 mit wladimir putin an der
spitze so handeln so wurde der erste
cyber angriff der geschichte arbeiten
und ja bei einem cyber-angriff auf eine
regierung die sich dermaßen stark auf
eine digitale infrastruktur stützt
antritt ist nicht schon um eine recht
große nur ist lanz gesamte verwaltung
wurde damals mehrere tage lahmgelegt das
bedeutete dass noch nicht einmal
krankenhäuser funktionierten aus diesem
grund hat die nato seit diesem tag ihr
hauptquartier für cybersicherheit
italien der nächste hauptstadt
eingerichtet
aber das ist noch nicht alles denn die
probleme von estland sind damit noch
nicht zu ende
neben finanzkrise zwei jahre später im
jahr 2009 wurde die estnische wirtschaft
durch die finanzkrise schwer getroffen
und besonders die ausländischen
investitionen waren vollkommen
ungeschützt plötzlich hatte die
regierung überhaupt kein geld mehr
zudem wollte sie in dieser zeit auch den
euro als währung einzuführen
aufgrund der euro-stabilitätskriterien
durfte estland nun also nicht einfach
nach belieben geld drucken
selbst wenn sie es gewollt hätten so
blieben nur zwei möglichkeiten die
ausgaben kürzen oder die steuern
drastisch erhöhen
[Musik]
im gegensatz zu anderen ländern wie
spanien fehlte estland erste option
innerhalb weniger monate entließ die
regierung über 10.000 angestellte was
einem drittel ihres gesamten personals
ex-politiker senken ihr gehalt und
frauen alle staatlichen investitionen
einschliesslich alle neubauprojekte
durch all diese haushaltspositionen sank
das esstische bip in diesem jahr um 16
prozent
zum vergleich das bruttoinlandsprodukt
der usa ist in den härtesten zeiten nur
um acht prozent dennoch nachdem estland
dieses schreckliche jahr 2009
überstanden hatte begann eine sofortige
erholung der wirtschaft da die politiker
die steuern nicht erhöht hatten und
durch eine auf flexibilität ausgelegte
wirtschaftspolitik ein gesundes klima
für unternehmensgründer geschaffen wurde
machten sich viele menschen die ihren
arbeitsplatz verloren haben
selbstständig lasst uns einen blick auf
die arbeitslosenstatistik werfen
zwischen 2008 und 2009 stieg estlands
arbeitslosenquote von 4 auf 19 prozent
damals war dies die höchste in ganz
europa noch größer als im gebeutelten
spanien oder krisengeschüttelten
griechenland binnen zwei jahren jedoch
sank die arbeitslosigkeit in estland auf
die hälfte
und aktuell liegt die zahl der
arbeitslosen in estland wieder bei 6
prozent
das gleiche gilt auch für die gehälter
heute verdient eine person die in
italien arbeitet mehr geld als jeder
beschäftigte in den meisten südlichen
ländern europas
um es kurz zu machen es land ist ein
modell niemand folgen sollte jetzt
werden wir sehen welche schlüsselaspekte
dieses land so erfolgreich gemacht haben
[Musik]
digitale verwaltung estland war
vorreiter bei der entwicklung eines
digitalen personalausweises mittlerweile
kopieren die meisten ja dieses modell
jedoch war bisher keine dieser kopien so
erfolgreich wie das original ist der
grund dafür ist dass der ausweis für die
bürger tatsächlich von nutzen ist so
kann jeder bürger mit hilfe dieses
digitale ausweises zum beispiel über das
internet unabhängig vom aufenthaltsort
an wahlen teilnehmen
eine registrierung ist nicht
erforderlich dieses besonders praktisch
wenn man im urlaub ist oder in ein
anderes land reist jeder experte weiß
was es bedeutet zur botschaft zu gehen
und darauf zu warten dass die
stimmzettel im heimatland ankommen es
gibt sogar viele wahlen bei denen die
aus dem ausland kommenden stimmen
verloren gehen in estland passiert das
nicht aber das ist noch nicht alles
estnische bürger können ihren
personalausweis nutzen um jede art von
dokument für die kommunikation mit
behörden zu erstellen einschließlich der
zahlungen von statt
vergesst die ellenlangen formulare für
die jährliche steuererklärung mit denen
die meisten regierungen ihre bürger
quälen im estland kann diese mit dem
handy immer wenigen minuten erledigt
werden dies funktioniert mit hilfe der
automatischen bank auskunft ist es schon
finanz angst so dass es über die
einkommen der bürger genau bescheid weiß
ist eigentlich in so gut wie jedem
anderen land auch der fall ist nicht
deutschland
der unterschied besteht aber darin dass
es in estland als überflüssig angesehen
wird die gleiche frage zweimal zu
stellen man geht also in seine bürger
profil und kann dort genauestens
überprüfen welche informationen das
finanzamt über einen zusammengetragen
hat ist also eine viel viel
transparenteres ist
danach bestätigt man diese angaben nur
noch durch einen klick und bezahlt seine
steuer
[Musik]
aber einen moment das beste kommt noch
stellt euch vor dass ein
regierungsbeamter
eure daten ausspionieren will wisst ihr
welcher beamte eure bank daten einsehen
konnte und momentan einsehen hat nun
gegen island bekommt er sofort eine
benachrichtigung auf dem bedienfeld
eures regierungspolitik ihr könnt sogar
genau die person sehen die sich bei
dieser information ansicht oder
angesehen hat und ein erklärung
anfordern warum diese das getan
das bedeutet es das hat viel mehr
transparenz und datenschutz kontrollen
als jede andere demokratie aber wenn du
immer noch denkst dass das nicht genug
ist dann kommt hier der grund warum es
land auf dem sunset boulevard der länder
angesiedelt
[Musik]
wir haben alle von großen unternehmen
gehört die ihre steuersätze in panama
oder luxemburg haben diese art von
steuervermeidung strukturen sind jedoch
für kleine und mittlere unternehmen oder
ein freiberufler so gut wie unerreichbar
nun in estland hat man festgestellt dass
man dringend neue bürger braucht und wie
ich bereits sagte befindet sich dieses
land in einer demografischen krise und
das wetter dort ist mies also wurde 2014
beschlossen
die hochmoderne verwaltungsstruktur
islams der ganzen welt anzubieten allen
menschen egal woher und jetzt werdet ihr
euch vielleicht fragen warum ist das so
nicht natürlich es ist nicht
gleichbedeutend mit einem bürgerwiese
und man kann es nicht als reisepass
verwenden aber es ist eine von einer
europäischen regierung ausgestellte
digitale identität und sie hilft einem
internationale transaktionen
durchzuführen oder ein bankkonto des
land zu eröffnen
ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass dies
für euch sehr nützlich sein würde wenn
ihr euch in der ukraine oder venezuela
dieser virtuelle pass macht es einem
noch einfacher ein unternehmen in
estland zu gründen sogar ohne dorthin
ziehen zu müssen oder ein spezielles
dokument zu benötigen okay ich glaube
ich kann euch jetzt sagen hören estland
ist ein steuerparadies stimmen nein so
ist es nicht die körperschaftssteuer in
estland liegt bei 20 prozent etwa
genauso viel wie zum beispiel in
finnland was estland anbietet sind nur
zwei dinge rechtsstaatlichkeit und
einfachheit glaubt dass es zu wenig nun
50.000 personen sind bereits registriert
in nur de und unter ihnen ist sogar der
japanische premierminister jean so aber
mit anderen worten island hat ein völlig
neues konzept
die flüssige staatsbürgerschaft und hier
kommt die frage glaubt ihr dass andere
länder diesem modell folgend werden
wartezeiten kommen in denen ihr von uns
seine nationalität wird wählen können
hinterlasst uns eure antworten im
kommentarbereich und vergesst nicht dass
wir jede woche brandneue videos
hochladen also abonniert unseren kanal
dann verpasst ihr kein beitrag wenn ihr
noch weitere informationen wollt klickt
auf die links in der beschreibung und
wenn euch dieses video gefallen hat gibt
uns ein like einen daumen hoch
wir sehen uns beim nächsten video
[Musik]